اوقع جيشه في الفخر الروسي هكذا اعلنها
الامريكان والرئيس الاوكراني يؤكد ليس
لدينا القدره على شن هجوم على الروس
فالينتات اسلحه الغرب ام انتهى الجيش
الاوكراني موسكو تحضر 400 الف جندي
للانقضاض على اوكرانيا
مقتل الف جندي روسي خلال 24 ساعه وبوتين
يرسل لدوله صديقه اسلحه نوويه فما الذي
يجري اوروبا تضع ثقلها على التنين الصيني
لايجاد حل للازمه الاوكرانيه وللمره
الثانيه
عليكم تحمل نتائج افعالكم وزعيم كوريا
الشماليه يبدا رده الحاسم بغواصه النبويه
مرعبه اثيوبيا تعلن تحدي مصر والسودان
رسميا ومكون يعود معتذرا للجزائر والحرب
بين امريكا وايران تشتعل في سوريا وهجوم
جوي يستهدف موكب وزير الدفاع اليمني ورئيس
الاركان فهل تلفظ الهدنه اليمنيه انفاسها
الاخيره هنا بوتين يحضر اسلحته المدمره
حرب اوكرانيا تواصل حصد الارواح وعداد
القتلى لا يتوقف وانهار الدماء تسيل في
الارجاء نعم هي هيئه الاركان العامه
للقوات الاوكرانيه تعلن انها قتلت اكثر من
الف عسكري روسي في 24 ساعه خلال معاركها
مع القوات الروسيه التي شنت نحو 40 غاره
خلال الفتره ذاتيه وقدرت الهيئه الخسائر
الروسيه منذ بدء الحرب بنحو 170 الف قتيل
قول الهيئه الاوكرانيه فهل هذه الارقام
حقيقيه برايكم لترد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قواتها تمكنت من القضاء على نحو 400
جندي اوكراني على خمسه محاور قتال اساسيه
خلال يومه ليسخن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الاجواء قليلا باعلانه ان بلاده
نشرت في بيلاروسيا 10 طائرات قادره على
حمل اسلحه نبويه تكتيكيه فما الذي يحضر له
بوتين بالقرب من اوكرانيا وعلى حدود
اوروبا اليكم المصدر اعلن الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
في بيلاروسيا عبر عشر طائرات مخصصه لهذا
الغرض بوتين اضافه ان عمليه النشر عباره
عن اعاده تنوضعي في الحقيقه فالدب الروسي
يستعد لمعركه طويله الامد بوتين يدرك ان
روسيا امام مصير حاسم ليصدر توج غير رسميه
بتوسيع نطاق القوات ورفع عدد العاملين في
الجيش لتكشف واشنطن عن حمله عسكريه روسيه
لتجنيد 400 الف متعقد عوضا عن تعبئه جديده
ومعظم المتعاقدين من العسكريين القدماء
والريفيين بحسب حتى ان نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي
اعلن تحضر موسكو لرفع عدد الجيش الى مليون
ونصف المليون جندي فعن اي استعداد نتحدث
ومن الاستعداد للحرب الى الحرب ذاتها في
اوكرانيا ومع تحول القتال في باخموت الى
حرب استنزاف للطرفين الروسي والاوكراني
نعم هذه الحرب تستهلك الجنود والذخائر هنا
يجمع قاده الغرب اعدادا ضخمه من القذائف
والذخائر لايصالها لاوكرانيا حيث صادق
قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي في بروكسل على خطه
[موسيقى]
الناس يمدونك بما تريد ليخرج هنا المستشار
السابق للبنتاجون دوجلس والذي قال ان
الرئيس الاوكراني
بارساله حشودا كبيره من قوته الى بغموت
فقد اوقع جيشه في فخ القوات الروسيه هناك
ومن بين ركام الاخبار جاء خبر انجليزي
عاجل حيث صرحت الدفاع البريطانيه ان
الهجوم الروسي العنيف على الاوكراني توقف
بشكل كبير فالقوات اصيبت بالارهاق فهل هي
كذلك حقا ومن ضجيج الاصوات المدافع
والقدائد الى هدوء السلام هنا زلنسكي يعلن
ان بلاده لم تتلقى اي عرض صيني للوساطه
والحوار او للقاء الرئيس الصيني مضيفا انه
طلب من بكين التعاون فيما يتعلق بخطه
السلام الاوكرانيه اذا الرئيس الاوكر يلهث
وراء محادثه
فهل خارت قواه وحان وقت الاستسلام ولكن
بوجه مشرف بينما اشارت صحيفه
الى ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يضغط على الرئيس
الصيني شي لاجراء محادثات مع نظيره
الاوكراني ويقول الاتحاد ان بكريين يجب ان
تضغط وتسعى للحوار مع كييف مثل ما تفعل مع
موسكو هل اقتنع الاتحاد بان بكين فقط هي
من تقدر على فك عقده الازمه الاوكرانيه
خلال ذلك قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان
الصين لم تزود روسيا باسلحه مهمه بعد
مضيفا انا لا استخف بالصين انا لا استخف
بروسيا معتبرا ان التقارير عن التقارب
بينهما ربما كانت مبالغا بها
هجمه قويه للرد على الامريكان
استفزاز من هذا الطرف يقابله رد قوي من
الطرف الاخر وبين اليوم والامس يبقى الرد
الصيني على واشنطن واحدا بعد ان استسلمت
الحكمه الصينيه لتكون القوه هي عنوان بكين
امام الامريكان وهي الدفاع الصينيه تعلن
انها اضطرت مجددا لابعاد المدمره
الامريكيه
التي دخلت مياهها الاقليميه في بحر جنوب
الصين مطالبه امريكا بحزم التوقف عن
الاعمال الاستفزازيه والا فان واشنطن
عليها ان تتحمل التداعيات الخطيره لهذه
الحوادث غير المتوقعه وفق الوزاره الصينيه
بينما تسر واشنطن ان مدمرتها تقوم بنشاطها
وفقا لحقوقها وحرياتها الملاحيه فكيف
ستنتهي هذه الاستفزازات الامريكيه
يخرج سلاحا مرعبا
يبدو ان الصواريخ لم تكفي لردعكم حسنا
انتظروا ما هو اعظم هكذا اعلنها الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون وذلك باعلان
اختبار بلاده غواصه جديده قادره على شن
هجوم نووي مهمتها التسبب في تسونامي
اشعاعي واسعا للمنطقه ردا على المناوره
الامريكيه مع جارتها الجنوبيه الغواصه
يمكن نشرها على اي ساحل او ميناء وسحبها
بسفينه سطحيه جاء ذلك بعد تجربه اطلاق
اربعه صواريخ كروز وكذلك قبل اطلاق صاروخ
سبعه عشر العابر للقارات احد اكبر
الصواريخ في العالم كيم بدا بهذه الغواصه
اجراءات الساحقه التي توعد بها فكيف سترد
واشنطن وسيول الاحداث
التطورات
اعلنت السلطات الليثيوبيه اكتمال تسعين
بالمئه من بناء سد النهضه رغم ما وصفته
بالتحديات والضغوط الدبلوماسيه والحرب
الداخلي فرنسا والجزائر تطويان صفحه
الخلافات بين البلدين بعد اتصال هاتفي
اجراه الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
عبد المجيد تبون عقب التوتر بخصوص ناشطه
الجزائريه امير بوراوي فهل عاد نكون
معتذرا وسائل اعلام يمنيه تعلن ان طائرات
مسيره استهدفت موكب وزير الدفاع ورئيسه
هيئه الاركان ومحافظي تعز والحوثيون ينفون
اي صله لهم بالحديد منسوب التوتر الامريكي
الايراني يبلغ حدا خطيرا في سوريا وبعد
هجوم بطائره مسيره ايرانيه الصنع على
قاعده امريكيه قتل متعقد امريكي واصيب
اخرون ليامر الرئيس الامريكي بايدن برد
سريع فقتلت الغارات الامريكيه 14 مقاتلا
مواليا بايران عبس العالم انفاسه وهو
يترقب الخطوه الامريكيه اللاحقه ضد
الموالين لايران في سوريا لكن بايدن هدا
من روعه قليلا واعلنا ان الولايات المتحده
لا تسعى الى صراع مع ايران لتتواصل
الغارات الامريكيه مره اخرى ويرتفع عدد
القتل الموالين لايران الى 19 فهل تشتعل
المواجهه بين طهران وواشنطن بوتين يحضر
اسلحته المرعبه على اطراف اوكرانيا
واوروبا تستنجد بالتنين الصيني لايقاف حرب
الدب الروسي على الاوكران فالى اين ستؤول
الاحداث بعد هذه التطورات
[موسيقى]